the two of you that that scene where
you're in bed together and rosemary
feels the baby kick
and she kind of like you see the light
bulb goes off and she goes i think it's
you know finally time to tell lee
i'm
[Music]
know it's too bad pregnant
hands
what you just say
i'm gonna have a baby
i don't understand
you're gonna be a father
and i'm gonna be your mother
kevin you've got your pjs on you've got
the bed head what was it like filming
that scene you know running around just
being so excited there was a lot of
anticipation going to that thing and and
i think we were we were
sort of um
foreshadowing that the whole season
behind the cameras pascal i talking
about this how was this gonna end what
was that scene gonna be what was it
gonna be and then when we got it
it's always like okay well we're doing
it and every time we've had the i say
this to her all the time
it's not quite what i was hoping for and
then we get into it and she's like what
are you talking about i'm like you're
right what was i talking about this is
great we laughed in between takes
we made jokes i think she farted under
the things and gave the blankets a
little i think she did that a couple of
times and we just laughed and stuff
and then as we were going it was just
kind of like
everybody was laughing the rest of the
crew was enjoying it as well and
watching them laugh and smile and joke
and it was like okay everybody's really
getting into that it's not just that
it was a really fun
scene to shoot we're having a baby we're
having a baby
lee
where are you going
we're having a baby
we're having a baby
i mean i mean not right now but we're
gonna have a baby
i know you're both parents in real life
does doing this art on television at all
bring you back to that time when you
learned that you were going to be a
parent
oh yeah absolutely absolutely i thought
of it many times even talking about it
now it brings it all back those were
life-changing moments in my life i did
have to
um work really hard and it was not easy
to get pregnant with my first son and
that moment of finding out that i was
finally pregnant i like
ran into
the bedroom and i woke my husband up and
it was cathartic and it was so joyful
and such a relief and and a release
we've been working towards like we've
wanted it for so long like all those
memories just came flooding back in
these episodes for sure
kevin do you uh do you remember the the
time you found out that you were gonna
be a parent at all like what's going on
with with lily and rosemary
yeah
yeah i certainly do i mean those were
the most special moments of my whole
life
i've always wanted to be a dad and when
it happened i just
it's really strange because
it's surreal you can't believe it's
happened but i always knew it was going
to happen so it was surreal and real at
the same time it felt like i mean it fit
like a glove and it kind of always has
and um
i say all the time i mean that's the
real job i've always wondered about you
know acting or other things or books or
whatever
hobbies i had when my kids showed up i
was like
[Music]
that's what i'm supposed to do i get it
okay i get it so yes i am able to draw
on that now for this i mean leah's only
just found out so performance wise i've
had one scene where that can where i can
get after that so i'm hoping that in
seasons to come if we're so lucky that i
will be able to draw on that even more
well if the powers that be are watching
this interview i am going to go on the
record we now just simply need a season
10. it's not we're hoping we're wishing
we need a season 10 at this point so
kevin what are you most excited to do
tackle experience in season 10. well one
thing i've always been on board with is
a pregnancy storyline i wasn't i wasn't
always sold on having more kids on set
but i am now but i was always
all over the pregnancy stuff because i
thought she and i could have so much fun
even if it was just um you know him
going out of his way to try and help her
at all possible times and them annoying
each other and the mood swings and then
sympathetic mood swings there's
the stuff is there's so much gold we've
always said that a pregnancy story line
between these two is gold and that i'm
looking very forward to pascal are you
excited to rock the bump are we gonna
see the pregnancy or do you think it's
gonna do a time jump and we'll just have
a baby i really hope that we see
a a chunk of the pregnancy because like
kevin said i really do think there's a
lot of gold there um
especially comedy wise with these two
any thoughts or preferences on team boy
or team girl here's an interesting thing
both my children are boys and both
pascals children are boys so we know boy
as well
interesting to throw a girl into the mix
and come on a mini rosemary that would
be like yes yeah that would be really
wild i mean how do you think they're
gonna manage
running a newspaper
running a lumber mill and also raising a
new baby it's going to be chaos but it's
going to be chaos but i will say if
anyone thrives in chaos it's it's
rosemary and lee as a team so i think
they'll do well but it will be hilarious
i think if we go back to elizabeth's
birthing scene it was quite dramatic and
quite intense pascal have you given
thought to
will there be a labor scene will it be
as dramatic as elizabeth's kevin and i
have talked about this a lot actually
and we've got some really strong ideas
but we'll see what ends up unfolding i
mean
as much as i would love to say that it's
up to us it's a hundred percent not
so but we have we have actually between
the two of us kind of mapped out an idea
of what we how we would love that to
play out and we'll just see
[Music]
you